l'épidémie repart comme l'affirment donc
jean castex cet après midi la tendance
est mauvaise et que dire du reste du
monde où l'épidémie galope déjà 5
million de morts selon l'om est-ce
qu'ils jugent elles mêmes le chiffre
sous-estimé se seraient deux à trois
fois plus de décès selon l' oms alors y
at il un risque de cinquième vague
doit-on craindre un nouveau confinement
ce serait le pire décryptage avec à nos
invités
[Musique]
avec nous pour en parler ce soir sur ce
plateau alexis poulain éditorialistes
d'affairé france bonsoir alexis merci
d'être avec nous en duplex le docteur
alex endoctrine laurent alexandre est
chirurgien et céistes de faire alexandre
vous êtes est l'auteur de nombreux
ouvrages
bonsoir à vous à vos côtés arnaud chiche
anesthésistes réanimateurs vous êtes le
fondateur du collectif santé en danger
merci à tous les trois d'être là alors
on va commencer par le point sur la
situation pas très brillant puisque la
tendance épidémique et est mauvaise je
me propose tout d'abord de jeter un oeil
sur ces chiffres publiés par santé
publique france 1866 cas supplémentaires
en 24 heures ce sont les données de 2
lundi 1er novembre soit hier six mille
six cent trente neuf personnes
hospitalisées
un peu plus de 2000 personnes 1000 60
heures précisément en réanimation ce
n'est pas une flambée mais chaque jour
ça monte un peu plus nous dit jean
castex ça veut dire qu'on va pas
échapper à la cinquième vague docteur
laurent alexandre comme le prédit
olivier ferrand
on peut craindre effectivement une
vaguelette mais pour l'instant les
chiffres qu'on a sont plutôt rassurants
par rapport à ce qu'on avait l'année
dernière on est toujours en dessous de 2
200 morts 150 morts par jour en moyenne
on n'a pas l'explosion à laquelle on
assiste en ce moment en russie 1 qui
n'arrivent pas à descendre en dessous de
1000 morts par jour on a une
augmentation des contaminations qui est
relativement logique parce qu'on
al'impression les épis de l'usto raison
que ce virus est en train de 2 ir un
virus saisonnier en tout cas d'acquérir
des comportements de virus saisonnier il
y a une augmentation qui ce qui arrive à
l'automne et nous avons aujourd'hui une
courbe qui ressemble un petit peu à
celle qu'on avait il ya un an mais avec
une différence c'est qu'elle est
retardée par rapport à l'augmentation
on a enregistré à partir de fin
septembre début octobre 2020 et puis
surtout on a un nombre de morts qui est
beaucoup beaucoup plus faible donc par
rapport aux comptes de l'année dernière
on a un ratio mort par nombre de gens
contaminés qui est moins élevé donc oui
on risque d'avoir une vaguelette ou une
petite vague non il est peu probable
qu'on ait mille morts par jour comme on
a pu l'avoir à certains moments lors des
vagues précédentes
donc il faut faire attention mais
personnellement et peut-être que je me
trompe je suis beaucoup plus optimiste
pour cette année que pour l'année
dernière faut pas oublier par exemple
convient de dépasser 88 % d'adultes
vaccinées en france et dans les pays
comparables alors ce n'est pas suffisant
pour stopper les contaminations et on
sait bien que la protection du lac
sainte contre les formes mortelles est
très forte mais elle est moins forte sur
la transmission dont il faut faire
attention mais je ne crois pas qu'on va
vers un confinement généraliser une
nouvelle fois avoir relativisé donc les
propos du gouvernement on en reparlera
d'ailleurs de cet aspect politique dans
quelques instants avec alexis poulain
mais d'abord arnaud chiche le premier
ministre qui a également évoqué la
pénurie de personnel soignant une frappe
de plus en plus fort sur fond de fatigue
évidemment en près de 18 mois de de
crise les rognons serait prêt en cas
d'afflux de nouveaux patients dans les
hôpitaux
écoutez vous mettez là le doigt
justement sur le gros problème c'est que
comme l'a dit le docteur alexandre
effectivement la situation n'est pas
différente cette année il ya une
vaccination qui a été fait mais le
problème c'est que comme il n'ya pas
d'anticipations de l'état de l'hôpital
et comme on n'a pas anticipé de toute
façon depuis cette première crise
qu'ovide le fait que le ségur ne
suffirait pas pour donner envie aux gens
de rester à l'hôpital on se retrouve
aujourd'hui alors qu'on n'a pas de pic
épidémique dans une situation ça a été
en france 4 trophic et donc en fait ça
veut dire que si on considère admettons
qu'on a encore 20 % de patients non
vaccinés je peux vous affirmer ce soir
que ces 20% là s'ils peuvent suffire à
paralyser le système sanitaire donc je
suis d'accord avec le docteur alexandre
il ya normalement devrait pas avoir de
problèmes de confinement mais tout est à
mettre en regard de notre état sanitaire
et l'état sanitaire aujourd'hui ces
fermetures de services d'urgence
fermeture de chou mur manque de lit
partout et forcément si jamais il ya le
moindre petit fou de malades ce sera
tout de suite la paralysie alors dans
les hauts de france les chiffres
augmentent un peu y'a pas il n'y a pas
de ya pas de pic mais ça augmente on a
tous un peu des patients comme dit dans
nos établissements il est très difficile
de prévoir parce qu'on ne sait pas très
bien chez la population vaccinée ce qui
va se passer en on n'a pas vraiment de
donner là dessus donc on a du mal à
prévoir l'afflux chez les patients
vaccinés est ce que comme on vous l'a
très bien dit ça diminue très fortement
le risque de kobe de grave mais ça ne
réduit pas zéro non plus donc en fait on
a du mal à savoir ça mais ce qu'on sait
ce qu'on sait c'est que si on n'anticipe
pas l'afflux possible des patients non
vacciner à l'hôpital ça va être la
catastrophe voilà les soignants sont
épuisées il manque de lit partout vous
entendez parler de la bronchiolite en ce
moment bon ben ya pas dix pour les
enfants donc autant vous dire qu'il y
aura pas dit pour les colis d'un ça va
être le même problème donc très vite on
va être en plan blanc si ça va pas très
vite on va devoir faire de la
déprogrammation la déprogrammation qui
est devenu un peu le juge de paix de
l'adaptation des hôpitaux c'est à dire
qu'en fait qu'on arrête de repérer les
malades pour dispatcher le personnel
normalement alloués à la chirurgie à
l'accueil de ces patients là et je vous
parle aujourd'hui de services d'urgence
qui ferme un peu partout en france ou
alors qu'il ne ferme que la nuit et
comme vous le savez le cowitz entre 9h
et 17h c'est jamais la nuit gars
rassurant en tout cas côté politique
députés et sénateurs on le disait avec
six poulains s'écharpent sur la
prolongation du passé ni terre propose
d'écouter philippe bas
échec de la réunion des députés et des
sénateurs dans la recherche d'un accord
sur le pass sanitaires le président et
le gouvernement refuse que le parlement
se prononce en février pour décider s'il
ya lieu de continuer à restreindre les
libertés pour combattre le qu'ovide tels
que le gouvernement lui veut prolonger
le pass jusqu'au 31 juillet les
sénateurs veulent lui l'arrêté en
février et revotés ensuite philippe bas
c'est quand même pas n'importe qui c'est
l'ancien général secrétaire général de
l'elysée il dit que ce terme un
continuer à restreindre les libertés
pour lutter contre le coc vite qu'est ce
qu'il entend par là alexis poulain bien
et reste un des libertés tout simplement
on voit bien que ce pass sanitaire il
est pas anodin et le problème c'est que
le gouvernement fait tout pour qu'il
devienne anodin qu'il devienne
finalement un élément de la vie
quotidienne ça ne doit jamais être le
cas parce que on est en train de renier
les libertés l'air de rien finalement
mais il ya un projet derrière qui est le
contrôle social qui est le contrôle des
populations et là il n'y a pas de raison
d'empêcher les parlementaires de revoir
la clause de revoyure en février je ne
vois pas pourquoi le gouvernement ne
voudrait pas le faire c'est qu'il a peur
c'est qu'il a peur qu'on arrête ces
mesures là parce que ça l'arrangerait de
pouvoir enjamber la présidentielle avec
ce pass sanitaire qu'elle est là quelle
est la raison en fait de ne pas vouloir
avoir un rendez vous démocratique
emmanuel macron depuis le début de cette
crise sanitaire gouverne de manière
antidémocratique qu'il gouverne sous le
sceau du secret défense on conseille de
défense en ayant fuit à la fois des avis
du conseil économique social et
environnemental des assemblées et même
des conseils qu'il a autour de lui en la
pression qu'eux rappelez-vous au début
de la crise était vraiment lui qui
décide est allé au théâtre non puis
finalement je vous confinés pendant un
mois on est en guerre mais bon le masque
bah c'est bon l'improvisation ça suffit
on en parlait avec le dr chiche il n'y a
aucune vision par rapport à ce qu'on
peut faire pour arrêter en fait
l'improvisation et prévoir que ce soit
une vaguelette ou une vague mais qu'on
ait une planification sanitaire
aujourd'hui de passy l'état sanitaire
c'est un passe simplement pour dire on
va encore pousser les français à la
troisième dose parce que certains
rechignent à voir cette troisième manche
bien sûr oui donc il est là pour ça même
s'ils ne veulent pas le dire et la
réalité c'est que
vous avez toujours des populations qui
sont loin et du vaccin et du pass et on
continue de creuser des différences au
sein même de la population française il
n'y a pas de raison le pass and i ter
rappelez-vous au début de la crise
macron dit il ne sera jamais utilisée
pour les activités du quotidien et
maintenant on veut le prolonger jusqu'en
juillet sans même avoir de clause de
revoyure alors qu'il devait finir le 15
novembre c'est à dire dans même pas dix
jours donc c'est n'importe quoi à un
moment il va falloir vraiment un
contrôle parlementaire on voit bien que
la vème république aujourd'hui elle est
défaillante que les contre-pouvoirs sont
défaillants et que aujourd'hui la
gestion de crise elle est le fait d'un
seul c'est emmanuel macron laurent
alexandre vous vous vivez ce pas
sanitaires comme levier alexis poulain
comme une restriction des libertés ou un
mal nécessaire
alors non je le vis pas comme une une
restriction des libertés j'ai pas
l'impression d'avoir une quelconque
diminution de mes libertés lyon en
france et en belgique et de sortir mon
téléphone portable et aimons pas ce
n'est pas l'impression que c'est une
restriction des libertés je me suis
dépêché d'aller c'est ma troisième
injection et je n'ai pas l'impression
d'être ni en belgique ni en france dans
un enfer dictatorial je remarque juste
mais à l'ex icône m ma position là
dessus que ce qu'il vient de dire sur le
gouvernement dans la plupart des pays
authentiquement non démocratique
l'entraîneur est en prison demain matin
ce qui ne sera pas le cas à alexis a le
droit de critiquer le gouvernement ce
qui prouve qu'on est quand même pas dans
une dictature à la chinoise et je ne
citerai pas ici d'autres exemples de
pays légèrement autocratique donc oui il
y à il ya un vrai problème sur la durée
du passé et j'en conviens bien je fais
plutôt partie des gens qui pensent que
ce serait pas mal qu'il y ait un nouveau
vote du parlement en février mais j'ai
pas l'impression d'être dans une
dictature j'ai beaucoup critiqué la
stratégie vaccinale du gouvernement y
compris sur votre antenne au premier
trimestre 2001 je ne suis toujours pas
en taule on ne m'a toujours pas envoyé
en camp de rééducation
franchement je n'ai pas l'impression de
vivre en europe de l'ouest dans une
horrible dictature pour revenir sur ce
que disait alexis à propos du bordel
français de la difficulté à régler la
crise regarder ce que font d'autres pays
merkel était considérée comme une heure
un génie des carpates de la gestion de
la crise ianor regarder les chiffres
actuels ils sont extraits en mauvais les
chiffres dérape on continue en allemagne
merkel a admis son échec ces derniers
jours son échec partiel même s'il n'ya
pas énormément de morts grâce à la
vaccination il ya un nombre de cas très
élevé donc je crois que nous devons nous
médecins à faire preuve d'une humilité
on a du mal dans cette guerre
virologique à nous projeter et à faire
de bonnes prévisions et on a dit
beaucoup de bêtises on a dit beaucoup de
conneries donc nous devons faire une
crise d'humilité les gouvernements
doivent écouter l'opinion edwards
et là je suis d'accord avec alexis doit
faire des passes sur des périodes
limitées c'est pour ça qu'il serait bon
qu'il ya un nouveau vote au printemps
mais on on ne peut pas aller jusqu'à
dire qu'on vit dans un horrible régime
dictatorial je pense que je pense qu
alexis exagère quand il dit ça en tout
cas c'était pas du tout mon pays ça j'ai
pas dit qu'on vivait dans un régime
dictateur jeudi que le pass ne doit pas
devenir un pass du quotidien le problème
c'est s'habituer à cette mesure là qui
est une mesure exceptionnelle va donner
la parole quand même arnaud chiche
pardonnez moi mais c'est passionnant ce
que vous racontez messieurs mais
rarement chez ge fait droit à la parole
aussi justement aller
nan mais globalement c'est plutôt pour
appuyer les propos de excusez moi ce
qu'on appelle en même temps c'était pour
appuyer appuyé les propos du docteur
alexandre effectivement malgré l'amitié
que je porte aussi à alexis poulain il
faut bien rappeler une chose je reçois
des appels
je suis désolé pour bien rappeler une
chose il faut bien rappeler il faut bien
rappeler une chose c'est que si les gens
se vaccine n'y a pas de problème avec le
passé ni terre donc ça c'est le message
envoyé on doit se faire vacciner ah
lalala lalala
et j'essaye de placer une dernière chose
effectivement
non mais on vous entend alors à vous
m'entendez oui donc enfin et
effectivement il faut faire preuve
d'humilité parce qu'on a déjà été
surpris et je suis un peu surpris que
justement on n'anticipe pas une
difficulté à venir sur un terrain
sanitaire déjà en difficulté moi ça ça
mais frey et finalement quand on entend
ça moi qui encore le passé ni terre ça
me rassure un petit peu parce que quand
on dit wait faudra te passe sanitaires
on joue un peu caïds ont joué un poker
on fait comme si on avait un système de
santé hyper robuste mais système de
santé c'est un c'est un château de
cartes aujourd'hui et il peut s'écrouler
moi je dirais aucun enseignement de
cette pandémie en tout cas sur 20 non
papa la hauteur palau pas la hauteur
non non aucun aucun aucun parce qu'en
fait la seule chose qu'on entend
aujourd'hui c'est que le ségur de la
santé a été fait or aujourd'hui on
assiste à une hémorragie de soignants et
une fermeture bloody partout en france
et l'état est sourd au fait que le ségur
est insuffisant c'est bien tout l'argent
du ségur mais les gens s'en vont donc en
fait là il faut faire en urgence un plan
qui va permettre de garder les soignant
à l'hôpital il faut faire des packs de
des packs de fidélité quand ils sont là
longtemps il faut faire des pas grand
âge quand ils travaillent dans des ehpad
il faut il faut vraiment fidéliser cette
population de soyons contents l'année
mais le fait que certains soignants ne
se soit pas fait vacciner est ce que ça
a pesé non ce que vous nous décrivez oui
il ya quelques il ya quelques exemples
effectivement de services en difficultés
il ya quelques exemples de services en
difficultés à cause de soignants qui
finalement dû arrêter de travailler mais
il faut pas il faut pas stigmatiser là
dessus ça représente pas énormément de
monde mais ça existe quand même il ya
certains services qui sont en difficulté
à cause de ça mais c'était déjà des
services qui étaient déjà très fragile
alors si vous enlevez deux personnes
d'une équipe de 6 forcément il reste
plus grand monde à la fin donc c'est pas
ça le vrai problème le vrai problème
c'est le terrain sous jacent est quand
on n'aura pas compris dans ce pays en
pleine période présidentielle qu'il faut
s'emparer du sujet santé en urgence
absolue le climat c'est important
l'éducation la justice c'est important
mais comment voulez vous qu'on parle
d'éducation et de protection climatique
si on n'est pas capable d'opérer les
gens de traiter les cancers et d'envoyer
le smur pour quelqu'un de 30 ans ou 35
ans du fer l'infarctus donc s'ils
voulaient on est dans une gestion de
pénurie est là et là et là on réfléchit
un petit peu à ce qui peut se passer
avec le co vide mais le problème c'est
que le terrain de base il est très très
très fragile et moi je voudrais insister
là dessus ce soir alors pas ciani
terreur voter oui probablement ce pas
trop mon domaine mais oui on vous je
vois pas pourquoi on pourrait pas leur
voter progressivement mais aujourd'hui
l'état des hôpitaux est tellement
fragile que le passé à lutter c'est une
très bonne chose et puis encore une fois
quand les gens se vaccine et ben ma foi
la vie comme dirhams docteur alexandre
moi aussi je montre mon je monte mon
téléphone et finalement on préférait
qu'on préfèrera étiez pas ça mais faut
quand même pas exagérer c'est pas
l'enfer en tout cas au niveau planétaire
l'épidémie galope 5 millions de morts
officiels recensés par l' oms qui
considère que c'est sans doute deux à
trois fois plus un en russie notamment
le président poutine a appelé la
population à se faire vacciner un
millier de morts par jour en russie un
docteur alex on en parlait il ya
quelques instants à moscou la
correspondance de maylis destrait
vladimir poutine a chargé ce lundi le
ministère de la défense de soutenir la
population civile dans la lutte contre
la pandémie notamment en participant à
la construction d'hôpitaux temporaire le
président a également rappelé que la
vaccination reste le meilleur moyen de
se protéger contre le coc vide c'est la
vaccination qui sauvent réellement d'une
évolution sévère de la maladie et d'une
issue létale actuellement des
médicaments sont en cours de
développement et j'en suis sûr seront
utilisés dans un proche avenir
aujourd'hui j'en ai parlé également avec
mes collègues avec ceux qui travaillent
là dessus pourtant le meilleur et le
plus universel des moyens de se protéger
et de se faire vacciner d'après le
kremlin la situation actuelle représente
une surcharge de travail extrêmes pour
les médecins et ne s'améliorera pas dans
les prochains jours des propos confirmés
par l' agence fédérale sanitaires
l'effet obtenu grâce aux mesures qu'on
est en train d'adopter et qu'ils le sont
déjà ne se fera pas ressentir
immédiatement
il faut du temps pour cela au moins une
période d'incubation est nécessaire très
probablement il faudra plus de temps il
n'est ainsi pas exclu que la semaine
chômé actuellement en vigueur dans toute
la russie soit prolongée dans plusieurs
régions celles de novgorod nord-ouest de
moscou à d'ores et déjà pris une
décision en ce sens mesqui peskov le
porte parole du kremlin a rappelé que
chaque région est libre d'adopter des
mesures supplémentaires comme le pass
sanitaires si la situation locale
l'exigent
selon le plan d'action et on sait dans
le décret résidentiel correspondant
jusqu'au 7 novembre inclus nous avons un
régime de jours chômés au niveau fédéral
figurent le même temps le plan d'action
du kremlin suggère que toutes les
régions disposent de pouvoirs spéciaux
pendant la période de la pandémie et en
fonction de l'évolution de la situation
épidémiologique peuvent prendre des
décisions de manière indépendante dans
le contexte de leur région particulière
enfin il ne faut pas croire les rumeurs
il faut se fier aux informations
officielles
au milieu de toutes ces mesures une
lueur d'espoir toutefois aujourd'hui le
nombre de nouveaux cas est repassé sous
la barre des 40 milles avec un peu plus
de 39 milles contamination reste
désormais à voir si cette tendance se
confirme dans les prochains jours alors
guère rassurant ce qui se passe en
russie laurent alexandre ça veut dire
quoi qu'en france on peut aussi avoir
des surprises
et qu'il va falloir en arriver à cette
fameuse troisième dose pour justement
s'assurer qu'il n'y ait pas trop de
mauvaises surprises
alors le problème de la russie c'est pas
la troisième dose c'est la première dose
pour l'instant donc le taux de
vaccination russe il est extrêmement
faible vous le savez on a dépassé les 25
% il ya très peu de temps et on voit
bien que il faut un taux de vaccination
à peu près du triple du taurus pour
avoir une protection correcte et la
comparaison entre la russie et des pays
comme la france montre bien qui a une
vraie protection avec la vaccination
alors aujourd'hui l'urgence pour pour la
france c'est pas tant la troisième dose
même si je suis tour et même si moi je
j'ai pris la troisième dose pour moi
c'est de faire la première et la
deuxième dose pour les quelques millions
de personnes qui ne sont pas encore
vaccinés et notamment quelques centaines
de milliers de gens de plus de 80 ans
qui ont un risque très élevé de mourir
s'ils font un qu'ovide et qui ne sont
pas vaccinés donc il faut se concentrer
d'abord sur la première et la deuxième
dose de nos aînés les plus fragiles où
le taux de vaccination n'est pas de 100
% ce qui est absolument inacceptable et
ce qui est très très dangereux puisque
on sait bien qu'il ya 180 fois plus de
chances de mourir quand on fait un coded
est con et seniors que quand les jaunes
donc la vraie priorité c'est de finir de
vacciner nos grands parents alexis cette
troisième dose elle passerait mal auprès
des des français certains oui clairement
on leur a promis de le retour à la vie
normale avec le vaccin rappelez vous
c'était la promesse initiale ont l'art à
ce moment à la même ce retour à la vie
normale bape pas vraiment puisqu'on
parle de vaguelettes d'épidémie on a le
pass sanitaires on a les gestes barrière
qui n'en finissent pas le masque qui
revient dans les écoles dans 39
départements donc non on n'est pas dans
la vie normale et on a l'impression
qu'on n'y sera jamais donc là la
première promesse elle est tombée à
l'eau et là on nous dit avec la
troisième dose promis cette fois ci au
printemps prochain peut-être à l'été
prochain ça y est on va retrouver la vie
normale évidemment que chat échaudé
craint l'eau froide les français se
disent une dose de doses trois doses et
puis quoi encore et puis on a des pays
où on parle déjà de quatrième dose pour
certains cas avec des comorbidités ou
des publics déjà affaiblies donc on sait
pas en fait si ça va marcher 6 quelle
est la durée d'ailleurs de protection du
vaccin contre les formes graves on
attend à des retours d'expériences
encore on a même des fabricants de
vaccins qui vous disent on ne sait pas
quelles peuvent être les effets
secondaires à long terme on ne sait pas
on ne peut pas vous dire on attend de
voir le patron moderna qui désirent une
interview au parisien je peux pas vous
dire pourquoi il ya des mieux car dit
chez les plus jeunes on sera peut-être
dans quelques années c'est pas très
rassurant pourquoi on ne serait pas là
dans les mois qui viennent pourquoi ya
pas d études des recherches pour éviter
justement même s'ils sont peu nombreux
ces effets secondaires donc il va
falloir vraiment un moment rassurer les
français 10 rebonds vous faites la
troisième dose elle est sans danger fait
la haie et voilà mes mais clairement il
ya des populations pour qui n'ont 2 ça
suffit la troisième bonjour les dégâts
voilà merci en tout cas alexis poulain
merci docteur laurent alexandre d'avoir
été avec nous également remercié arnaud
chiche qui nous a quittés donc il ya
quelques minutes merci à tous les trois